breaking the FBI now says an armed
attack on a naval airbase in Texas this
morning was terrorism what appears to be
the second Islamic radical attack
targeting a US military base in recent
months the suspect was killed and one
member of the security team that stopped
him was injured national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin is at the
Pentagon with the breaking details
tonight good even Jennifer
good evening Brett is the second
terrorist attack on a Navy base in the
United States since December this
morning at Naval Air Station Corpus
Christi in Texas a car came speeding
through a gate which triggered vehicle
barriers to deploy and stop the car the
driver then began shooting injuring a
security guard that sailor was wearing a
bulletproof vest and has since been
released from the hospital
the suspect was reportedly an Arab man a
US official tells Fox and was shot and
killed during the attack we have
determined that the incident this
morning at the Naval Air Station Corpus
Christi is terrorism related the scene
is still being processed we may have a
potential second related person of
interest at large in the community but
we would encourage the public to remain
calm and if you see something say
something
today's attack comes just months after a
Saudi pilot in training went on a
shooting rampage killing three u.s.
servicemembers in Pensacola Florida on
Monday the FBI and Attorney General
William Barr held a press conference to
announce that the Saudi pilot who went
on the shooting spree at the Naval Air
Station in Pensacola had been in touch
with an al-qaida leader in Yemen which
the FBI learned after cracking the
encryption on the shooters iPhone the al
Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula leader in
contact with the Saudi pilot was
abdullah al-maliki Fox News has since
learned the al-qaida handler was killed
in a us-led operation it is not clear if
today's attack in Texas is linked
sources tell Fox the shooter in Texas
today had quote a lots of ammunition and
it took about five hours to get the body
because local authorities thought he
might have been wearing a suicide belt
and had to call the bomb squad Brett
FBI on the scene there Jennifer Griffin
live at the Pentagon Jennifer thank you